- [Kelly] Welcome back everybody.
We are here with Jennifer Garner.
(audience cheers)
Her new Netflix Movie is
called, "Family Switch."
It got us thinking about
how many iconic families
we've loved in movies
and shows over the years,
so it is time for a game celebrating
those fictional families,
this is One Big Happy.
(melodic music)
♪ One big happy ♪
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] You can go so
many different ways with
the ending of that.
Heavenly Father,
a little help with the game, please.
(angelic sound)
- [Kelly] Okay, thank you.
God comes here, yeah.
- [Man] Well, hey Kelly
and Jennifer Garner.
Oh my me, I am such a big fan,
I am such a big fan.
Don't tell Kelly but I'm
rooting for you. Okay,
- [Kelly] Whatever God,
you traitor. You Judas.
- [Man] Don't sass back, now
Here's how the game works, girl.
I'm gonna read a trivia question
and the answer to that question
is the name of a famous
fictional family or character.
Now steals are allowed and
I'd advise that you wait
until the end of the question to answer,
but like most things in
life that's up to you.
- [Jen] Okay.
- [Man] It's Jennifer Garner
versus Kelly Clarkson.
- [Kelly] Yes.
[Man] Benadryl Chicken versus
Wet Towel in the dryer.
- [Kelly] Yes.
(audience laughs)
- [Man] And a family size prize.
A family-sized prize for
their respective side
of the audience is on the line.
So this is big, this is big.
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Man] Okay.
- [Kelly] Focus, focus, focus.
- [Man] All right, these
two are very competitive.
- [Kelly] Thank you,
ma'am. Thank you, ma'am.
- [Man] Yup, shake. That's good.
- [Kelly] I wish you luck, kind of
(audience giggles)
- [Man] Okay. Here we,
wow. That's just nasty.
You're playing dirty
already, Kelly. Here we go.
Here's the first question.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- [Man] This family forgot
their son, Kevin. Not Once,
(button dings)
(Kelly shouting)
- [Man] Jennifer?
- [Jen] McAllister family, "Home Alone".
(bell dings)
(audience cheers)
- [Man] You got it. It is the McAllisters.
- [Kelly] It's so, it's
so fast. It's so fast.
That was so fast.
- [Man] There you go.
That's, oh, look at that
one point for Jennifer.
How's that feel, Kelly?
- [Jen] Oh my Gosh
(audience clapping)
- [Kelly] That's really
good. You have speed, okay.
(audience laughing)
- [Man] The McAllisters
with that big ass house,
they probably paid $200,000
for that back in 1990.
(Kelly laughing)
(audience laughing)
- [Man] Bunch of bull. Okay,
here's the next question.
In this family, when the
father met the mother,
she was bringing up
three very lovely girls.
- [Kelly] Oh!
(button dings)
"The Brady Bunch".
(bell chimes)
(Kelly cheers)
(audience cheers)
- [Man] It is "The Brady Bunch".
- [Kelly] Yes! Yes.
(audience applauding)
- [Man] We got ourselves a tie here.
This is a game now. Marsha,
Marsha, Marsha. Poor Jan.
Poor Jan.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Man] Okay. Here's your next question.
The Winslow family on "Family Matters".
(button dings)
- [Kelly] Carl Winslow, 'Family Matters".
(Kelly stammering)
- [Jen] He hasn't asked
the question yet, Boo.
(audience laughing)
(buzzer ringing)
- [Man] Well, I'm sorry
Kelly. It looks like you
jumped a gun.
- [Kelly] It's Urkel, and
it's "Family Matters",
and that's the show, and.
- [Man] You jumped the gun, Kelly.
(bell chiming)
- [Jen] Oh. Do I get that point?
- [Man] I'm gonna give you a point.
Just because you're Jennifer Garner,
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] What kind of show is this?
- [Man] God's in control now.
Okay, now let me read the whole question.
The Winslow family on "Family
Matters" was always being
interrupted by a lovable nerd named-
- [Kelly] Urkel.
- [Jen] Urkel.
- [Man] It was Urkel.
(bell chiming)
(audience clapping)
There you go. There you go.
- [Kelly] I waited for the whole question.
- [Man] Okay, here's your next question.
Mary Poppins went to take
care of Jane and Michael.
- [Kelly] I don't know.
- [Jen] Banks.
(bell ringing)
- [Man] It is the Banks.
(audience cheering)
You got it.
Okay. Here's your next question.
Now, what was the name of
the family from both TV
and film who had some odd
members, like an uncle
who turned on light bulbs?
(button chimes)
- [Jen] The Adams family.
(bell dings)
- [Man] It is The Adams family.
- [Kelly] Wow. Wow.
(airhorn blares)
- [Man] Uh-oh, that
sound right there means
like we have time for one
more famous fictional family
and this one is worth 400 points.
(Kelly chuckling)
- [Man] Very excited.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- [Man] Here it is.
This is for all the chips. Here we go.
This family went on a number of vacations,
including a Vegas vacation and a,
(button dings)
(Kelly stammering)
- [Kelly] Chevy Chase, Chevy Chase
- [Jen] The Griswolds.
- [Kelly] Griswolds, but, yeah
you, okay.
(bell chimes)
(audience cheers)
- [Man] It is the Griswols.
(airhorn blaring)
- [Kelly] No, I will not take
it. I will not take it, I
only remember Chevy Chase
in the European vacation.
I did not remember Griswolds
in the moment, she gets it.
(audience cheers)
- I didn't get it.
I didn't get, I won't take it.
- [Man] Jennifer Garner is
the winner, you've done it.
- [Kelly] I won't take it.
I could remember the
entire, the rusty hat.
I could remember all of
it, but not their name.
It's interesting. Okay.
We're all winners though.
We're all family. We're all winners here.
- The Vitamix immersion blender
features a 625 watt motor
with four blades on five speeds,
and comes with multiple accessories
that can blend tough ingredients
in the palm of your hands.
That's nice. And you're all getting a
Vitamix immersion Blender bundle.
(audience cheers)
"Family Switch" is now
streaming on Netflix, so
be sure to check it out.